a tremendous job as always by Peter king
in his in his column his must read
Monday column football morning in
America from NBC sports back here on the
Rich Eisen show Frogger where he was in
Kansas City which we'll discuss in a
second Peter Craig how are you Peter I'm
doing fine
we've got now what about it seems close
to 24 hours after that huge non call
where do things stand do you think on
this front with the league and the
officiating as we head into Super Bowl
53 Peter I think it rich I think
everything everything is on the table I
think you know you everything from Al
River on job to the job of the officials
the side dredge and the down judge most
notably you know I was told yesterday
that this is a site judge yeah call most
likely but also could have been flagged
by either the down judge or the back
judge the back judge in that particular
case is likely to be in center field
so he's likely not to be on that you
know basically that's likely not to be
his job but it could be depending on
where the play takes them and then I
think as far as replay goes you know
Bill Belichick instead of four years I
don't mean that I have a scintilla of
influence on anything but I've written
it for years if you do not increase the
number of challenges you have in a game
and you shouldn't if you done do not
increase the number of challenges you
have in the game you ought to be able to
challenge any call on the field at any
time you ought to be able to challenge
outside you ought to be able to
challenge or false start you know it
replay is about getting a game right and
for everybody who says oh my god the
games would be five hours long no they
wouldn't you wouldn't you wouldn't be
able if you used all your challenges and
with four minutes to go in the fourth
quarter that play happened and you
didn't have one left look tough tough
bananas
so most coaches I think what would end
up most coaches in my opinion would end
up saving a challenge for the end so you
know there's all kinds of things rich
but I get the sense from the league last
night that that quite literally
everything is on the table right now for
for the review of not only pass
interference but the officiating
department in general you know I think
time of game Peter is usually a hand
ringer for just league management you
know I don't think an NFL fan right now
is saying you know champ game is a
crisply played game that's I think it's
same thing in baseball too like it seems
like right now baseball is gonna
institute a pitch clock rather than a
change in the shift rule and I you know
I don't think a single baseball fans
like you know what these games are too
long period so the question is is what I
think so in baseball though rich I
really do I think that the four hour and
15-minute nine inning games are
ridiculous and every time the Red Sox
and the Yankees play but people don't
care but I don't know especially the
World Series game it's not that we're
talking about this but it's Fresno World
Series games when they're you know when
they're going on till twelve twenty at
night on the East Coast but anyway I
know I'm the one who took us down that
rabbit hole but I but my point is though
is that to me I think when you are
having to talk about the importance of
the game and whether it was either
officiated properly or played in a
manner that's more entertaining time
time of games shouldn't matter so what
is holding it back is it just the sense
of trying to keep a human element in in
officiating Peter I rich I think look
when things like this happen when things
like this play happened those are the
questions that everybody's asking but
thing is the competition committee is
not going to even put anything about
this on the table until they go to the
Scouting Combine and then really that
the competition committee and the league
begin discussing rules like this when
they all meet in Indianapolis at the
Scouting Combine Roger Goodell is there
Torrey Vincent all the officiating
people are there and the competition
committee members meet at the Scouting
Combine and they start the process of
this of what they're going to do for the
new year until they do that I don't know
what they're going to do and I I think
there has been zero momentum uh to get
every play reviewed you know the
Belichick proposal zero and so now we
have to find out if potentially
potentially it was not a lock but it's
it was going to have a very good chance
if potentially when the wrong team goes
to the Super Bowl now all of a sudden
somebody's ox has been gored and it
really really means something Peter King
here on the Rich Eisen show however I'm
sure la fans listening to us right now
or Rams people or you know other x' who
really didn't have much skin in the game
might be thinking Peter the the right
team did go will the one that came back
from 13 points down the one that has
Aaron Donald and then sue playing their
heads off in the middle of the defense
Mike what did you take out of that Rams
victory going into Super Bowl 53 to give
you an idea that they perhaps could win
this thing I mean the RAM you know first
of all I think that Jared Goff really
really proved something yesterday you
know rich a month ago when he had his
eminently forgettable performance
against the against the Eagles at home
and and as you know as he saw after that
game you know Shawn Shawn King Shawn
McVeigh he was just absolutely he looked
quite distressed
about everything on his offense
including the guy who quarterbacks it
but Jared Goff made three beautiful
passes yesterday
dropping dimes into a bucket like 33
30-yard throws they were absolutely
right on the money and and I think that
is the first thing that gives you a
chance that thinks you have a chance are
that in that environment when you're not
going to hear anything the whole day to
be able to play well as a quarterback
when your communication is not working
and all that stuff
I thought it was really an impressive
comeback for golf and rich I think one
of the big early questions I would have
in this matchup
Wade Phillips is going to have to figure
out how to get to Tom Brady okay Tom
Brady yesterday in my column head you
know Tom Brady threw release the ball
yesterday in an average time of 2.2 3
seconds he was not sacked for the second
consecutive game now is that like 90
past droughts this postseason has not
been sacked was only pressured six times
yesterday and so you look at all that
and you basically say this guy this guy
is like then and that line is almost
impregnable right now what is Wade
Phillips going to have up his sleeve to
be able to pressure Brady Tom Brady is
unbelievable Peter King here on the Rich
Eisen show and you got a chance to spend
some time with him after the AFC
Championship game just one-on-one
sitting in his lock of how did you find
him Peter rich you know was amazing it
was almost in the midst of a Nick Ulis
you know championship game locker room
mayhem store when he was he was really
really Placid III think he was almost of
what I would call he was he was a little
bit he
I mean this is a weird way to look at it
but he was almost dazed by the events
because as he said to me he said nine
nine Superbowl is crazy it's ridiculous
it's unbelievable I I can't even fathom
this I mean here's the guys that playing
football in the NFL he's been starting
football games for 18 years and he's
been to the Super Bowl nine times rich I
don't care I don't I don't care how
incredibly wonderful great everything
Patrick Holmes is and out to me hearing
there's only one cool today that reminds
me of my home's now and you know
entering the league like this and that's
Dan Marino you know in the time I've
been covering the NFL hi
and I don't care how go to quarterback
you are to go to the Super Bowl nine
times in 18 years
I'm telling you Tom Brady was with days
just trying to think of all of it and
he's just he's ridiculously appreciative
you know what he told me that really
struck home and I went back and looked
it up when I went back up to the press
box after spending time with him he said
you know the big thing here is
continuity and you know he was telling
me during what Ivan beers been there for
every year of the Belichick era
McDaniel's Dantes Carnegie there for
almost every year and so you know why
that matters rich because yesterday at
11 o'clock in the morning the Patriots
offensive players reported for their
their their last meeting before the game
and Josh McDaniels stood in front of the
room and he put in eight new plays in
that day's game play and they ran four
or five of them during the game so this
is the and you only do that when you're
comfortable with the team that you have
and you know that your players can
digest these things and the one other
thing I would tell you is that I wrote
today amazingly the Rob Gronkowski
passed the last third and ten conversion
for Brady on the overtime drive before
Rex Burkhead took at the final 15 years
last completion
that play was not even in their game
plan
McDaniel just invented it it had been
used before but he just he threw it in
there because he saw a coverage it was
Eric Berry he said oh my god we can take
advantage of it it's so great about Bill
Belichick staying power and continuity
you know and Peter this is the stuff
that we're gonna be chewing on yet again
I mean this is the third straight Super
Bowl that New England is made and you
mentioned how it's now nine times out of
18 it's the chicken or the egg
conversation of who means more Brady or
Belichick to the to the dynasty and
maybe it's just a 50/50 split here
because I don't know of another team and
every team knows it's a matchup League
everybody does I mean Shaun McVeigh's
been brilliant in its first two years to
show how it's all about matchups and
scheming and making sure that you get
the right situation at the right time
you know that that it seems though that
New England is the best at boiling down
matchups year to year week to week snap
to snap and Brady's the one who executes
sit like a cyborg and and you know Romo
was calling it out right pre-snap every
single time yesterday and they just they
they nail you almost every time and you
can point you could take a look at the
times where they don't where it's
reversed like the Miami miracle where
Gronk was somehow for some reason on the
one-yard line trying to make a tackle
it's so rare when the script gets
slipped like that on them Peter it's
unbelievable
I look I rich I was all over the
Patriots this year in the wake of a you
know of creating Brandon cook and with a
you know with with with another deep
weapon I thought the Patriots receiving
corps was just it was not nearly good
enough and it was gonna really bite him
at some point and you know what for a
good portion of the season it did but
the Patriots benefit from a couple of
things the AFC East stinks to high
heaven
and the Patriots can take advantage of
that by getting so many wins they don't
have a Kansas City Chiefs and Los
Angeles chargers and I mean and and
until the last couple of years Denver
Broncos in their division so I mean you
know there's nobody there's no reason
there's not I mean so the the Patriots
get a chance to took to mold their clay
on their team all season and then be in
place late in the season you know to be
able to get their guys to play well
enough together so that the fact that
you don't have a big star in your
receiving core doesn't end up fatally
wounding you ask the poll question of
Peters we go out the door introduce it
for the first time in our show today
Chris Brockman go for it all right Peter
who's the legacy changed the most on
Sunday drew brees Sean Payton Andy Reid
Sean McVeigh Tony Romo I mean I'm I
really want to hear all of this game
because everybody said it's so historic
it's ridiculously good and I've got a
bunch of people say why didn't you
praise Romo in your column today I'm
under the football game I'm not watching
it on TV right I almost said yesterday
but only way I will listen to it at one
point this week and I'm sure he was
wonderful but I guess you know if you
give me those choices I would say
McVeigh because there was a general
feeling around the NFL this especially
from a few coaches how's the genius
doing house you know and there's all
this hey boy wonder how's he doing great
playoff game he had against the Falcons
last year so I guess if given those
choices I would say McVeigh because Hays
in Super he's in the Super Bowl 12 years
after he was a wide receiver at Miami of
Ohio against Julian presences that
happened very often against Julian
Edelman by the way in 2007 they were on
the same field same day
unbelievable how these things work and I
did not know that October 6 2007 please
yummy of Ohio against Kent State of
course correct right yep Edelman Edelman
yeah bridge yeah if I write that as the
lead to my column this week can I seal
it without giving you any credit Peter
there's statistics in a book you I just
I heard about it and I instagrammed it
out and I tweeted it out it's really
amazing go for it take it go we always
Peter thanks for the call you take care
you bet that's Peter King there's nobody
better that's why he's in the Pro
Football Hall of Fame at Peter
underscore King check out his football
morning in America peace right there the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience